if three times a number is equal to
three halves what is the number
so let's just say that our number this
unknown number let's just call that x so
we could say three times three times
our number x
is equal to
is equal to three halves is equal to
three halves so now we just have to
solve for x and so if we want to isolate
an x here on the left hand side the most
obvious thing to do is
3 times x if we divide by 3 we're going
to be left with just an x but we can't
just do that to one side of the equation
if we want to maintain this equality we
have to do it to both sides so you
divide both sides by 3 and we're going
to be left with
x
is equal to three halves divided by
three that's the same thing as
three halves times one-third
three-halves times one over three which
is going to be equal to
one-half so x is equal to one-half and
you can verify that three times one-half
is equal to three-halves